hallo mein name ist luca herzlich
willkommen hier heute zu einem video auf
der website hot netz.de bei dieser
webseite geht es darum dass man bilder
von sich oder von irgendeiner anderen
person hochladen kann und diese website
sagt einem dann wie heiß man ist auf
einer skala von 1 bis 10 die person von
denen ich bilder ausgesucht habe und die
ich dann auf dieser website hochladen
werde habe ich in zwei gruppen
unterteilt was und youtube daher würde
ich sagen fangen direkt an mit dem
ersten star und zwar mit break das foto
von drake habe ich jetzt hochgeladen und
hier steht ihr attraktives score ist ok
also trade hat eine 8 der zweite profi
die nicht für heute vorbereitet habe ist
justin bieber das ins bild wird hier
auch hochgeladen und er hat nur vier
okay gut also die frisur sitzt auch
nicht die allerbesten allerdings direkt
weiter mit dem nächsten promi uns fast
wieder ein musiker beziehungsweise eine
musikerin und zwar ist es william nicht
wirklich sehr gespannt und zwar die bbc
also bin ich bisher wirklich kompletter
spitzenkandidaten machen allerdings regt
weiter mit einer boygroup und zwar bts
bin ich mir ehrlich gesagt nicht allzu
sicher welches gesicht er sich die
website jetzt hier schnappen wird
sie haben sechs also ist wahrscheinlich
dann so einen durchschnitt der ganzen
truppe wir von acht promis die ich für
diese kategorie vorbereitet habe habe
ich nun schon hoch geladen wie die irish
führt immer noch mit zehn von zehn
allerdings kommt nun der sexiest men
alive wayne the rock johnson hier bin
ich auch ultra gespannt weil er acht
okay er ist auf jeden fall von den
männern bisher mit vorne dabei
allerdings meine damen und herren kann
ihnen diese nächste person wie
vorbereitet habe vom thron stürzen und
zwar ist es der politiker axel voss ist
ja bekannt für seine ab laut filter für
seinen artikel 13 4
ok damit ist er mit justin bieber
tatsächlich am herzlichsten allerdings
vom vorletzten kandidaten denen ich hier
für diese kategorie promis vorbereitet
habe und zwar dass es wieder eine
politikerin und zwar unsere
bundeskanzlerin angela merkel haben ich
ebenfalls sehr gespannt ich glaube sie
wird nicht wie so oft sex angela merkel
ist angeblich heißer als justin bieber
kam er allerdings nur noch schon zur
letzten person dieser kategorie und zwar
ist es wieder ein politiker und zwar
donald trump präsident der vereinigten
staaten von amerika hat bei hotness
punkt einen score von 5 also komplett
durchschnitt für diese kategorie können
wir dann einfach jetzt mal festhalten
dass die heilig herzlichen glückwunsch
du bist in der kategorie promis
die heisseste person mit einem
kompletten volltreffer zehn von zehn
wunsch allerdings kommen wir nun auch
schon zur zweiten gruppe uns bei den
youtube an und da würde ich sagen kann
wir direkt an mitreden vorzeigebeispiel
schlechthin katja krawitz das wäre
natürlich wahnsinn wenn sie direkt zehn
verzichten
ich komme also direkt die erste person
die ich hier bei den youtube an
vorbereitet habe katja glaser witthaut
die rechnet zähne raus ich werde nicht
mehr allerdings direkt weiter wird einer
ebenfalls weiblichen youtube drin und
zwar babys beauty palace da bin ich
ebenfalls sehr gespannt katja hat eine
10 von 10 erhalten und das muss ein
fehler sein
die nächste person wird
safe 11 von 10 punkten bekommen days
luca hat ja und bibi haben mit jeweils
zehn punkten natürlich groß vorgelegt
ich das kann nicht sein aber gut ich
würde sagen wir verlassen weil dem
deutschen youtube frauen bewegen uns in
richtung amerika denn der nächste
kandidat für heute.de ist mister biest
vista dies macht ein virales video nach
dem anderen und hat drei punkte
allerdings bin ich wirklich gespannt was
die webseite bei unsere nächste person
sagen wird denn es ist diese
unglaubliche resonanz gab es ja auch
sein cdu video 5 vom 10
also ich bin bisher der hässlichste
youtuber den ich rausgesucht habe wo wir
allerdings gerade schon von mir sprechen
als nächstes habe ich meine freundin
jule vorbereitet hier bin ich auf jeden
fall auch gespannt wie es seit 10 alter
jedes jede youtube nicht ausgesucht habt
ist er hat zehn und sehen wir kommen nun
allerdings bereits zum vorletzten
youtuber die draußen gut habe und zwar
ist es julien
hier bin ich ebenfalls sehr gespannt
weil sein gesicht auch halb verdeckt
wird er hat auch 42 wir sind beide
gleich hässlich nun ist das video
allerdings schon fast vorbei und wir
beenden das ganze mit der achten und
dementsprechend auch letzten personen
die ich hier in dieser youtuber gruppe
draußen super und zwar ist das james
charles h bin ich sehr gespannt da ist
der einzige männliche youtuber in der
kategorie ist der sich schminkt und er
hat 8 also heißester youtuber ist james
charts aber von allen youtube an die ich
für dieses video hier raus und habe sind
es julia bibi und katja alle drei auf
platz eins mit voller punktzahl und ich
und bleibe hässlich
[Musik]